I can't stand Hollywood that I used to
that's what I started for right you
wanted it I wanted it bad all right you
do a a damn fine Joe Pesci impression
I'm Joe Pesci all right I got a call
who's who's this you'll know who it is
you dirty rap fake money well first of
all you don't even sound like me you rat
bastard so then I was like no I think I
sound like you a little bit
people like you don't
door yeah
January 6th
SNL I just saw Hollywood at its at its
peak in bands and I was like wow it
really is just a show hey
the likes of what you're doing right now
there's no better thing in life you
control your destiny
[Music]
okay thanks for coming in
um the reason why you're here is because
some of your recent posts have given off
kind of the uh wrong connotations
I mean I don't have like an only fans or
anything if that's what you're trying to
say well um it's been brought to my
attention about these posts such as this
one
it's a good one
great this one oh the bicep on that was
good
um I'm not supposed to have been that
way that's a weird angle and this one
I mean okay fine I'll get that's not the
worst it's not the best not the best or
even close I don't I still don't
understand what you're talking taken
separate and apart there's nothing
that's sensibly wrong with these but the
totality of all these posts kind of
gives the illusion that you're um what
how should I I put this
Gary
come on come on yes yes Gary that's what
the totality is Sam who's very rarely
right I don't want to agree with him
he's Russian he doesn't get it come on
Carrie you know me no Gary okay who was
it come on who was it who reached out to
you from a daily wire to try and hire
you it was good time
good time Joe at dailywire.com don't you
see what's happening he doesn't see
don't see what's happening here Gary he
wasn't trying to hire you he was trying
to you no he's rushing he doesn't
get it yeah he should get it if he's
Russian well look you go to a Russian
bath house they hit you over the head
with a hammer and the chips fall where
they may right wait you've been to
Russia no he has not been told
no one cares Gerald this isn't about you
Gary did he send you any follow-up
emails after that no I I don't think so
you can try to reach out to you again no
no make check your spam yeah the
straight emails yeah no but he's
definitely trying to find me
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
with you I still have the red tide so I
apologize I have a lot of ninjas in my
mouth I don't know how to say that word
uh correctly uh but that sound means
it's it's Monday through Friday 10 a.m
Eastern so that's when you can tune in
don't rely on notifications don't rely
on the subscription box Bell do you have
the uh Monday through Friday 10 no
no
if you're listening you know you can hit
the rumble button uh but we have uh I I
realize I always have I always say we
have a lot to get to today and people
like that's like your equivalent of
really big show you know really big
that's a little something Sullivan there
I need to work on it we're gonna be
talking about today
Elon Musk and the CBC also his warning
on AI I will admit you know what before
I do anything else admonish me please
admonish me I will admit just do it now
Tim just just
I was I don't want to say wrong about AI
but the the Quantum Leap has been so
fast that it is far more concerning than
ignition wait come on what are you
talking about what when it last night
last week or so when you said you
weren't really all that concerned and I
was like I don't know I don't recall it
and I don't believe you can prove it did
brickles call you he called you at home
yeah I don't know why we have that app
let alone installed it across the cloud
so we'll be talking about uh
government-funded media uh with the CBC
as well as CNN by proxy here in the
United States DeSantis is taking a war
to Disney right now which is very
interesting because they're going super
super gay which on everything how much
more gay can they well you know what
hold on to your butts and uh I want to
ask you this who do you think is
contributing most of the racial divide
here in the country that's the that's
the question of the day because there's
been the Kansas City shooting that took
place it's being misrepresented by CNN
we'll get in to that and uh they are
very selective in which shootings they
cover and how they cover them and they
are flat out wrong it's not no longer
can you attribute to ignorance what I
believe can be attributed to to malice
so CNN if you want a civil you want a
civil race war this is how you start a
civil race war we'll get to that in more
but first Gerald a number two CEO how
are you I am doing much better than you
sorry you're still sick yeah well turns
out that talking for Two Plus hours
isn't really good on the old vocal cord
so what I'm trying to work out was sick
but that was a bad idea yeah it was a
bad idea there's always a Tipping Point
and I tipped and uh you know him you'll
love him uh you saw his his reel there
on the the outset we're really glad to
have him here you've been asking for
them uh you can check out his tour dates
at jimbrewer.com May 6th and may uh 19th
actually in Florida that's uh is it
where does it say May 19th is the one he
really wants May 19th in North Largo
Florida Jim Brewer how are you sir I'm
doing great Steve you don't even look
different from the old clip lips you
just have shorter hair I have shorter
hair maybe maybe a little more bags
under the eyes no you always had sleepy
eyes so it's like that that's the beauty
of as you having them when you're young
I look high all the time yeah I love it
which is a good thing because then that
you know people the they they they don't
have high expectations well police
officers like sir have you been uh
partaking like here's my license oh well
geez I feel sorry for you okay just to
take that back I'm sorry for asking yeah
no ticket for you sir I apologize yeah
where's my bags just keep getting worse
it's like Tales from the Crypt you used
to be able to bounce a quarter off this
it looked like a Korean call girl now
those all right
foreign
[Music]
here is a middle-aged man who is
bragging about his
girlfriend's uh hotness which by the way
first off don't be a braggart
secondly see if you can understand why
the boasting might be misplaced
now we have a special guest is a lovely
encountered Joshua who literally woke up
like this so he slept and he slept in my
clothes the point is I do that often you
look very pretty let's go with that
people always ask us what's your age
yeah but why do you care just know the
biggest Gap in our relationship is
between my teeth
laughs
um because your girlfriend
how does that guy wake up and just not
feel the urge to Putt-Putt golf here's
the thing
that guy was watching Aladdin like the
rest of it and rather than having a
crush on Princess Jasmine he's like I
want to bang Jafar in the dungeon scene
that's what
floats my boat terrible we've gone past
the point like not Everything Is
Beautiful first off and this is for for
you know heteronormative couples by the
way and not everything is worthy of
Praise we reached this point where
everyone thinks that they are worthy of
self-esteem she wakes up this way do you
mean crack Bender or meth whatever your
preference white to probably math well
and lack of teeth meth that's probably
you know yeah lack of teeth that fits if
that was a man who's still identified as
a man you'd say well there's probably an
eating disorder send it with Dylan
Mulvaney and we just ignore it like well
how about we look at the BMI how about
we look at the dental records I love how
the HR thing is cloaked by well she's uh
he I mean he's a she yeah that's what
you should be focused on she's my hot
girlfriend that used to be a man that he
still calls Josh I guess that's dead
naming on Jim looked very confused you
should be I I thought it was a sex
trafficking advice
I mean if you look at the guy staring at
her the whole time yeah it's like
protects me now I get you a good price
it makes sense that man's a un
Ambassador
she's running for office somewhere yes
exactly she's on a peacekeeping mission
except she's at war with uh she's at war
with flossing so
let's go plaque has won that War
uh let's go here to uh this is a theme
today
of you know why don't you trust your
institutions we're constantly blamed
right we're all blamed you don't trust
your institutions you don't trust uh the
this government a lot of people out
there they don't think that this was the
most safe secure legitimate oh by the
way if you see this YouTube dump button
while you're watching on YouTube if you
see this
there you go that means that uh what
you're seeing on YouTube is still going
on on Rumble because uh if you don't
believe that these are the most free
fair safe elections of all time why do
you mistrust your institutions if you
think of the media is biased why do you
mistrust your institutions well I grew
up in Canada and I've talked about this
for years you don't need to go to
Venezuela to have entirely
government-funded news when I grew up in
Canada all we had was the CBC uh it is
government funded so this brings us to
you know with all the crazy news that
comes out of Canada we figured that we
actually need to turn it into a segment
because it's very important to see it as
a cautionary tale it's America light uh
Elon Musk called them out the prime
minister is mad about it this is our
first installment of no Canada
[Music]
that's nice that's very simple not bad
simple yeah we're probably gonna add
some lyrics to it feel better than
Gerald's yeah it's still better than
Gerald's Stinger he had like three
minutes to do this one as well I know I
know I know I don't you can mustn't be
afraid to drink a little bigger left so
last week uh the Canadian opposition
leader Pierre uh polev however you say
it the right wrong way in English called
for labeling of the Canadian
Broadcasting Company also known as the
CBC uh as state media here you go in a
controversial move social media giant
Twitter has labeled the cbc's Twitter
account as quote government-funded media
the news was on Twitter by conservative
leader Pierre pauliev polyev was the one
who had asked Twitter to add that label
to the CBC and this is how they what
they do in the media right it's a soft
bias team they go quote
government-funded media well who funds
them the government so why the quote I
felt like it
thank you
but the quote would imply that I know
what it implies yeah yeah yeah I'm
pretty good at my job so this weekend
Twitter marked CBC as
quote 70 percent government-funded media
and then the CBC protested saying that
there are less than 70 government funded
and this is why I love in uh autist
billionaire being in charge because Elon
Musk responded changing the label to 69
now to be clear before you fact check it
it's actually 65.6 percent so close yeah
so close but so close I think that's a I
think that's a little more accurate than
what they would claim that they are not
government funded I love it and uh a lot
of people don't realize this I talked
about this you know in Canada when
people talk about the corporate media
the corporate media in the United States
yeah it has its problems but the
alternative is government-funded media
that obviously the main benefit is
decentralized Media that's why we're
here that's why we're on Rumble by the
way hit the like button if you're on
YouTube or comment below smash the
rumble button we want to bring as many
of you over from YouTube to rumble as
possible that's the solution but
certainly not government media which you
see in socialist countries and in
countries like Canada and in the UK so
Justin Trudeau the Prime Minister over
there is um obviously really mad about
uh the labeling issued a statement
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
we have recently switched to drinking
water bottles out of water out of uh
when we have water bottles uh out of a
plastic uh sorry away from plastic
towards uh paper
um
[Music]
the researchers guys you have to be on
top of the wrong clip sorry this is
again Trudeau was responding to the
labeling of government media here is the
clip now you sometimes hear about
liberal bias in the media these days how
they're constantly letting off our
government letting our government off
the hook
for no good reason
frankly I think that's insulting
clear that they let us off the hook for
a very good reason because we paid them
600 million dollars
I'm sorry do we have the right clip yeah
I got it I'm sorry Jim you deserve
better than this this is a guess this is
unprofessional he's a guest in our house
I don't know
uh serves right across the country
delivers local news and local content in
many regions of the country
that yes has been challenged over the
past years
but the idea of adding to that challenge
is and laying on
by attacking
this Canadian Institution
attacking the culture and local
institutional important to so many
Canadians
that really indicates
the values and the approach that Mr
polyev is putting forward see they
pulled the same trick the institutions
the Canadians value
it looked like he was it he looked like
he was trying to hide from saying the
people are catching on that with thieves
them and we steal their money and we
make them work and we The Peasants are
rising and we gotta span Tick Tock
immediately too much information
I feel like I'm watching every Disney uh
villain sidekick
that's all I see when I watch these like
someone should smack you and be like
you'll reveal the plan
change your face you're giving it away
you're giving it away yes master use the
right words establishment
government which is a nice word for evil
demonic stealing enslavers I'm sorry
they're for our the people well here's
the thing too and this will bring us to
CNN afterwards because they're doing the
same thing in the United States again
because these people are this goes back
to journal list again Andrew Breitbart
you see his poster up there he released
something that was called journalist I
believe in 2009 where the white house
then the Obama administration had a list
of journalists who were used to
disseminate the information that was
favorable towards that Administration
and they were told which stories to bear
this has been going on for a long time
the differences in Canada it is directly
funded by the government you had this
guy running for office people who don't
know this year when they about the
corporate media do you want the
alternative to be when Trudeau was
running I think there was an indie I
can't remember who was the NDP member
but someone said and when I win we will
make sure to undergird our robust news
media institution 100 million dollars
introduced at 150 million well guess who
won
they're buying media with your tax
dollars and just in case you don't think
CBC is a joke here are some of their
best headlines quote the I use that
accurately the pleasure and Peril of
snitching on your neighbors during a
pandemic uh by the way it's always Peril
just so you know spoiler alert pleasure
how a non-binary Winnipeg student lives
with mix of body Euphoria and dysphoria
well I'm sure there's temporary Euphoria
from the drugs and then why socialist
Susan Neiman says wokism is not leftist
okay these are the headlines from the
CBC Corporation who by the way fly in
the face of science you're talking about
a place rate of 14-day quarantine to
come back into your own country you're
talking about vaccine mandates you're
talking about shutting off the bank
accounts to truckers who are protesting
their government this is it's it's scary
stuff and Canada is really close to the
United States and I mean close also as
far as how they uh interact with the
globe as a country sure they're
inconsequential no one really cares
about them we should take them over
without even skipping lunch but the
point is it's the most similar culture
and Country to the United States that
exists and it's not that far off from
where we are headed well don't don't
forget his famous line that you don't
have a right to gun ownership for so he
said you don't have a right to defend
yourself yeah defend yourself at all in
Canada you said that proudly yeah right
by the way he shut the trucker's funding
off while saying they had a right to
protest right until they ran out of
money yeah but by the way let's bring
down let's bring down the pike that
digital centralized currency so please
Elon Musk my favorite artist uh spoke uh
last favorite African too favorite
African-American
he spoke last night with Tucker Carlson
African-American autistic genius
uh also uh by the way we'll talk about
this on uh mug Club more later which is
this is the last free uh week of mug
Club lotto.com it's what allows us to
bring people in like Jim like Nick he's
going to be here Thursday like Hodge
twins like Brian Callan as we grow
expand shows please do consider
supporting it Elon Musk talked about the
threat of AI as well in that same
interview if that's the case for AI and
we only put in regulations after
something terrible has happened it may
be too late to actually put the
regulations in place the AI may be in
control at that point you think
that's real it is it is conceivable that
AI could take control and reach a point
where you couldn't turn it off and it
would be making
the decisions for people
so I was just making wardrobe notes from
Tucker Carlson
I wrote down no no more bow tie
ditched
is that more on mugler because I feel
like Jim you can just go off on the AI
thing I was like we need to give Jim a
wide open Lane and we'll talk about it
on Monday yeah yeah because there's so
much to get into it yeah I just I can
actually see Jim oh how he sits oh wow
because he sits forward Yeah well yeah
and normally I can't see who I'm talking
to over there so okay well you know what
sit back you don't need to admire him so
this brings us to by the way to uh
another story that is reflective of
American Media so you guys
or you watching listening you may not
have heard of this story you probably
did hear about it but you didn't hear a
lot of follow-up uh the shooting that
took place in Kansas City and by
shooting I should frame this
self-defense is what it seems to be and
this will bring us through the claim
from the media and the truth and they
acknowledge gun violence in very
specific ways and they deny it in other
ways for example they'll tell you that
there are 30 40 000 uh gun deaths here
they don't tell you that a huge portion
of those are suicides they don't tell
you how many defensive uses of firearms
exist right they don't tell you uh that
when they tell you that children the
leading cause of death in children are
are guns at the vast majority of them
are age 16 to 19. we've done segments on
all of these but here's a sort of a
microcosm an 84 year old Kansas City uh
gentleman Andrew Lester has been charged
following the shooting of a black
teenager so right away you hear the name
Andrew Lester shot a black teenager you
know what Walgreens is getting burned
down somewhere
the uh the the the d-perm uh spray is
being put behind the glass case no so uh
a shooting of a black teenager which of
course obviously anytime there's a loss
of life that's easy thank god well
anytime there could be he was shot I
know he didn't lose the head as well
initially the media did report that he
lost his life but well they did but also
because he was shot in the head so I
think it was kind of assumed was it like
it must have been grazed there's no way
you get out the next day shot that well
you know what there could be a silver
lining he could be like that one Bond
villain where the bullet made him
stronger as it got more lodged into his
brain you know and that was a white guy
yeah
so uh Kansas City man Andrew Lester
charged following a shooting of Ralph
yarl is this black teenager who um
mistakenly showed up at the man's house
this is what you heard this one
captioning the nation's attention a
white homeowner is now facing charges
for shooting a black teenager who rang
his doorbell now Kansas City opened fire
on 16 year old Ralph yarl through his
glass front door that was last week
y'all says that he went to the wrong
house to pick up his younger brothers
and the homeowner started shooting
almost immediately when he answered the
doorbell the family's attorney almost
immediate mom says it's inexplicable
that police release a suspect on the
night of the shooting why I have black
people rang a doorbell and then have a
white citizen
shoot him in the head
first and then shoot him a second time
I mean there is no way you can justify
this uh there are many ways
yeah many many many many many many ways
you can justify it now you can't justify
it if you just see the world through
white bad black good right right white
must be the assailant black must be the
victim and that's my concern with the AI
the people programming it don't actually
value human life or intellectual
diversity they see everything through
the prism of identity this gender good
this gender bad this race good this race
bad there's no way to justify shooting a
man at your front I can give you at
least a million scenarios off the top of
my head and I wouldn't even break a
sweat it depends on the context so let's
walk through the claim how they've
presented it and then we'll present to
you what we believe to be the truth as
the evidence is emerging and the cops
obviously believe to be the truth and
then we'll show you how they memory hold
it once the truth started coming out
with CNN so the claim was that Ralph
yarl was simply shot for knocking on the
door CNN you saw the clip but they said
a white 84 year old homeowner who
allegedly shot and wounded Ralph you're
all black teen after the 16 year old
went to the wrong home to pick up his
siblings like they just said there's no
appropriate scenario right a white man
shot a black man this is what they do
and so of course because of that within
hours mob of protesters took to the
streets
or other attacks what do we do
apparently nothing
[Music]
get the Indian drums yes
well where's Nathan Phillips when you
need him I know right they're stealing
his gig by the way when black lives are
under attack you know when black lives
are under attack every weekend in
Chicago you pretty much aren't doing
anything for that but when one white guy
answers the door that's 84 years old at
night and shoots somebody all of a
sudden it's take to the streets right
yeah exactly what we got to say there
Jim well I just I'm always fascinated
how quickly they organize drums and
photographer it's like a doctor
yes how'd this form so quick I know
that's amazing music man yeah right like
this shooting happened 76 to Ramones the
big parade
I don't know what happened the blood's
in the Crips shut out in South Central
L.A they started doing Oklahoma
so of course a bunch of high profile
leftists not waiting for the facts this
is why I say thoughts and prayers are
actually appropriate sometimes rather
than acting rashly it's no longer a
virtue right it's about being first it's
about being outraged first which is why
we actually try and wait so you have
Ibrahim X candy tweeted the white man
who opened the door did not see a lost
16 year old boy he saw a threat shot
Ralph twice once in the head to kill him
that's what I was saying but he didn't
kill him he did not Sean King a
professional white guy made subversive
threats saying uh we have the name and
the address of the man who shot Ralph
yarl local whites are making excuses for
the man but what I clearly understand is
that he never shot any of them just
Ralph ah so the only reason he may not
have shot other white people in the
neighborhood and by some other white
people we mean every other human being
he's ever encountered in his life ever
is because of their race what about all
of the other black people what about all
the other Latino people what about all
the other Asian people remember stop
Asian hate what happened with that no no
maybe there's some context here maybe
it's because the man wasn't just at his
door selling well they don't sell Girl
Scout cookies I think like they sell
pine cone description the Cub Scouts I
don't know right now it's really just
the Cub Scout leaders going door-to-door
saying shh don't tell so
sign this NDA that's their claim now
here's the truce okay
they're conflicting accounts of what
happened and again what's important as
the police they talked about how the
police just let them go according to
Andrew Lester's affidavit and it does
seem like it's more accurate and again
it passes the reason test more
he opened the interior door and saw a
blackmail approximately six feet tall
pulling on the exterior door storm door
handle he stated he believed someone was
attempting to break into his house so
what he was saying is someone was trying
to open his door right trying to open
his door do we know what time this
occurred uh I don't know but it seems
like it was dark it seems like it was
dark out at night and again this is
something first off let's let's assume
that this is all that happened well
what's the law of the state do you have
the right to stand your ground and does
the context matter if he's trying to
open the door and trying to get into the
house if you're an old man in your house
or and you don't have someone else who
can protect you or you don't have a dog
you should obviously have a dog that's
what I recommend first and foremost you
probably feel the need to protect
yourself yeah who knows what could
happen here do you have do you have to
wait now until you become a victim I'm
not saying this is an ideal scenario but
the idea that he was just going around
pulling pulling a Death Wish Bronson is
it does not seem to be the case and it
doesn't pass the sniff test and it
didn't pass a sniff test for the cop oh
no wait the cops are racist why do you
mistrust your institutions you shouldn't
trust the cops uh well depending on
which cops by the way if they're coming
by to take your children and send them a
CPS because they're not transitioning
you should trust the cops or if they're
coming to take your guns away you should
trust the cops uh but you should trust
your media you should trust your
Administration you should trust the CDC
but why don't you trust the cops who
said that this man was justified
you should trust Don Lemon well why
don't we just get an unbiased report on
it right because this what he said is
that he shot twice in a matter of a
second or two is what he said in his
statement right a couple of seconds
really quick bang bang he didn't go up
like gangster style and he finished
it and then he ran away and so he
immediately the homeowner picked up his
phone and called the cops yeah so this
wasn't like oh goody a black guy's at my
door right that's not what this series
is that's what the media is they're
going to use that as a sound bite on me
oh boy I've been waiting for this day
for a long time
I'm gonna get him with my one good eye
this revolver my non-saggy eye I'll show
him it's the last time those people of
color call me prune face from Dick Tracy
I'll show them it's Mr Peabody's Revenge
Bang Bang
so CNN covered this story non-stop for
24 hours yeah while completely ignoring
what's been happening in Chicago in case
you've forgotten here's a quick reminder
[Applause]
and notice the only thing we talked
about yesterday the only thing that gets
them to scatter and by them I mean the
writers is a gunshot which of course
they want to remove from you in Chicago
think about this for a second we just
talked about Washington state they're
going to be basically taking kids away
from parents if the parents don't give
them gender affirming care don't give
them sexual transition surgeries when
they're young right and then they want
to disarm you
it's a really really scary time in this
country and what's even more important
is is how few times they addressed some
stories out there that are more
relevance and again more relevance to
you because
disputes happen let's just kind of take
off the table the fact that they're
lying about this but disputes happen but
there are things that affect you for
example hey maybe you shouldn't go into
this neighborhood hey do you have
children maybe you should make sure that
you get your children out of this area
because there's there's disregard for
human life and violence instead because
of a political agenda they don't cover
those which by the way harms you as an
actual citizen why don't you trust your
institutions
that's what's scary
and here's a clip uh I warn you if
you're watching this is a PG-13 show
anyways if you have kids they probably
shouldn't watch this it's pretty
disturbing uh it shows a gang of yeah
look a gang of young since they're doing
the black young black youth attack and
the reason I mentioned this is because
this is statistically far more common
it's statistically far more common when
you look at interracial crime statistics
which they decided to stop reporting
accurately in 2016 that young black men
are far more likely to attack a white
woman than an old white man is a young
black but that's a statistical reality
again I say that because I think it's
information that matters to you and your
day-to-day life
um here's a video of a group of uh black
young men attacking a white woman in
that this should make your blood boil
now here's the thing I don't know the
context there I know the woman would
have been safer if she hadn't been there
for sure did she think did she know that
she was walking into a violent mob or
did she follow CNN because this matters
do you know how many times CNN has
mentioned what's been going on in
Chicago
you know how many times in the last two
days nine times compared to the mention
of the Kansas City
shooting self-defense 57 times jeez so 9
versus 57. here's something even more
it's actually eight because one of the
only mentions of Chicago came from a
republican Governor Chris Sanu talking
about mass shootings if you you don't
you have no concern about oh of course
we have concern about sensible gun laws
of course look so folks talk about let's
say a red flag law okay let's take a
place like Chicago they have one of the
most restrictive red flag laws in the in
the country they have some of the
highest rates of gun violence I think a
red flag law has been implemented less
than a dozen times in the past couple
years so it's easy to say yeah we'll
just you know take the guns from those
with mental illness but it's much harder
to actually implement the realities of
that are much more it's not just about
taking guns he says named Chris sununu
it's a new new I said Sanu that was not
your fault you should admonish me I made
a note I've only ever read his name I've
never actually heard it pronounced
because I don't live in New Hampshire
and I don't even care about it yeah I
have a problem so 57 times mentioned
that one incident between two people
in Kansas City eight times on CNN do
they mentioned Chicago which by the way
could keep what if they discussed
Chicago right instead of posting maps to
the private residence or having guests
who've posted maps to the private
residence of Mr Lester how about they
post crime maps of Chicago so that
people know which areas to avoid what if
they did that 57 times instead of lying
eight times and one time mentioned by
that Governor hey comment below hit the
like you think that might be useful do
you understand that this isn't just
about the news lying it has a direct
impact on you and then the more upset
that you become they blame you it really
is it's a quintessential narcissistic
behavior they blame you well I didn't
mean it that way well uh that was
actually an accident and actually if you
take that as an accident look what you
made me do
that's the sequence of events well and I
think the frustrating part for us is
that we want to wait for context on
every single one of these cases but when
you come out and say white man shoots
black kid right you don't give us the
opportunity now we have to go wait a
minute was this a racially motivated
thing because that's exactly what you're
saying and that's what stirs people up
and that's what gets protests going and
Walgreens getting burned down like we
talked about a minute ago when it could
just be a case of I don't know that
Ralph did anything wrong by the way he
may have genuinely gone to the wrong
house pulled on the door because he
thought he was may have given permission
all that could be true but we can't sit
here and think about it because you guys
have told us it was a white and by the
way all that could be true and it could
mean it still doesn't mean that Lester
is a racist exactly it could still mean
that he saw a strange man right you know
jiggling the handle on his door trying
to get in he didn't know what's going on
got scared and maybe he made a mistake
yeah it's all those things are possible
yeah even Ralph the kid he's a street
kid right if I'm a street kid and I'm at
a door and I see a white older man
approaching and clearly I could tell if
he's stressed I would say amen I
I may be at the wrong I'm looking for my
little brother yeah yeah I mean there's
a lot of elements but you're hitting on
a subject where I'm glad what you're
doing because when it comes to media
media should be instead of saying Media
news it should say so the demons said
today Don Lemon is a pure demonic evil
human being anyone fund they are demons
and the minute you take away the word
news and media and say so let's see what
the demons are trying to do people will
start comprehending more because that's
all they are they shouldn't have the
word media it's too friendly and nice
yeah you know what I agree with you
demon and it's not even Alex Jones in
that show no in that chair today we're
gonna start a race war a white man shot
a black kid go
get the trombones and the drums
they've got them at the ready don't let
them see the real takeover
it's dedicated to just those items oh
where's Al Sharpton yes don't worry
about the prompter he can't use it
anyway there was a so who tinga of a
white
many
black Utah
this morning
you think in Chicago
no one's messing with the property yeah
he is
he in get my drum set so nobody here's
something else too by the way we'll talk
about this more later this week this
deserves a bit of a deep dive yeah I
think it's important to stop using the
mass shooting numbers that the left
wants you to use okay they're they all
try and say consistently that there have
been more mass shootings than there are
days uh this year that's not true
they've changed the definition of mass
shooting okay so the definition that
they're using a mass shooting it comes
from the quote investigative assistance
for violent crimes Act of 2012 and the
term mass killings means three or more
killings in a single incident with mass
shooting I believe it's three or more
injured that was a change from the FBI
definition which was a mass murder is
usually a number of murders four or more
occurring during the same incident so
the numbers that they use and by the way
even before that what you would consider
mass shooting being someone who actually
walking in and shooting a massive amount
of people that's not what we're talking
about the vast majority of these mass
shootings that they categorize to tell
you that they need to ban your AR-15s
first off don't use long rifles they're
inter-gang related violence in places
like Chicago in Los Angeles where three
or more people get shot
but then they don't tell you about
what's going on in Chicago or in Los
Angeles so we need to stop using those
numbers because it doesn't actually
reflect what they want you to believe is
the threat if you believe that there
were two three four mass shootings like
columbine like Sandy Hook every day it
would be far more easy for you to get
behind a magazine ban if you believed
that it worked when you understand that
the huge portion of these are really
intergang related violence incidents or
workplace incidents or fights that break
out between people who happen to have
firearms in certain areas of the country
you may actually come to the opposite
conclusion that you should be allowed to
protect yourself hey isn't that
important that's your job media smash
the rumble button if you're watching on
Rumble right now because that helps with
the out I don't know if the rumble
algorithm matters just watch it Monday
through Friday 10 a.m it's actually a
little bit more fair we can actually get
the live views but isn't it interesting
they want it instead of saying gang
violence they want it to be mass
shooting why is that when you think Mass
shooter what are we always told it's
some white guy who's you know messed up
now that's not always the case but it's
always some white guy going and doing a
mass shooting when you think of gang
violence what do you think
messed up white guy of course yes right
exactly and on the streets of South
Central L.A it's definitely I saw West
Side Story no it was those damn Jets
it's pushing this narrative again like
if we could focus on gang violence but
the problem with gang violence is that
it's predominantly black on black gang
violence that we would have to be
talking about and we can't talk about
that so we have to call it mass
shootings so people think of white guys
and everybody's safe and right science
yeah and we have to ignore the massive
amounts of uh trans Shooters recently
and by the way this is very reminiscent
we don't have all the facts like we said
there are still multiple scenarios where
this I can tell you this okay I'm
willing to hang my hat it's not what CNN
told you that a white guy just walked
the door and shot a black guy for no
reason I guarantee you that's not the
case maybe it was an early shoot maybe
it was a bad shoot doesn't mean this guy
is racist he certainly wasn't going out
hunting black people I don't know if you
know this probably the best place to
hunt black people if you are a racist is
not in your living room
so I don't buy it but it's very
reminiscent of Makai Bryant remember
that story Makai Bryant where the cops
showed up oh man when she was uh she was
the one who was stabbing she was about
to stab a girl a cop committed a heroic
another black girl who called the cops
she was about to stab the girl the cop
shot her by the way while she was
mid-stab and just so you know if you're
watching on YouTube our episode on Makai
Bryant where we supported the police
officer was removed because it said it
was reveling in the death of somebody no
we were reveling in the saving of an
innocent life that was about to be
established and by the way LeBron James
immediately tweets out the face of white
supremacy or the face of racism the
cop's face basically who had shot
without having any of the facts at all
right about what was going on
unbelievable that cop should have been
celebrated he got there and immediately
within seconds so CNN covers it a very
specific way so does uh so does ABC NBC
CBS right all the main news outlets and
then when we say hold on a second we
actually have footage at that point it
was breaking that this girl uh was in
the process of going stabby stab you
with another black girl who had called
the cops and the cops saved that black
girl's life we get removed by the way
not just us it's just right we're
standing in the way as the old adage you
right comment below if your post on
Makai Bryant got removed a lot of you
when you tried to correct the record had
that removed why well because of course
media big Tech they work in the same
industry and of course they take their
calls to action from the government see
Karen jump you see what we know what's
going on with Twitter right now as Elon
Musk is revealing see when Jen sackey
said that Spotify needs to work with the
White House to better censor content see
what they did with YouTube and removing
the dislike button because nobody likes
watching Biden's shitty speeches as he
soils himself see all of these examples
it's not a conspiracy when it's
happening out in plain sight uh we're
going to move on here to Disney gay
stuff uh Jim it's Jim brewer.com right
what your podcast is on Friday too right
uh yeah everywhere it's on Friday yeah
okay Jim it's Brewers versus others
people don't know it's just universe but
I put Bruins
yeah
it's my first and only show I didn't
remember myself now your kids are uh
they're all way older than Disney age
now correct but we used to go there all
the time to as a DVC member really yes I
am you still are well yeah because you
you know they get you for like 30 years
what is that one you're a Disney
Vacation Club member so you gotcha and I
would give it to France and blah blah
blah but no we we would go to Disney all
the time but now we get rid of all our
Disney stuff and no one was none of your
children were ever eaten by a by an
alligator uh oh no so you gotta oh no
they could have been yeah they could
have been where that kid got it well we
used to let we would hang out right now
right by the don't hang out here sign
because of alligators no no no I mean
listen there are signs and you know
flirt but you're a little kid you're not
really you think Disney you're super
safe there's no there's no uh there were
no fences it was just your it's an open
beach and there's there's boats there
and all that and your little
two-year-old toddlers playing along and
next thing you know it's Jesus you're
out I don't know but still to me they've
been around for a long time one
alligator death in the State of Florida
to me is still remarkably stable I don't
want to fault them for that's a pretty
good track record that's a good track at
least the one that they told you yes
well that's about
turns don't count yeah
uh so uh Ron DeSantis and this is an
important segment because I think look I
think there are a lot of people out
there who like both Rhonda santis and uh
and and Donald Trump and I think that a
lot of people on the fence going who's
the best candidate for the job
um and I think there's some contrasts
here that are interesting but first
let's talk about Disney so in case
before we get to this you were wondering
just how woke Disney is now this is
Disneyland but then we'll go to Disney
in Florida and what the Santa's is doing
uh in in Disneyland California
um they just added now Pride After Dark
Nights
[Music]
thank you
um
I don't want to be self-important
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this day sometimes I like slow news days
because we can expand on some subjects
here so yeah hold on oh no ah
I don't know if you know Casey was
gagging yesterday when I coughed and he
heard a gurgle I saw the spit
the napkin
yeah
he has a worse gag reflex Casey last
week he can't see bananas people thought
it was fake we had Tim tool man eat a
banana and he threw up in a bucket
multiple times what do you guys do and
your dad starts dropping a deuce and you
gotta clean it
you'd be surprised as to what doesn't
gross him out he wakes up in a puddle of
his own filth but a banana sends him
over the edge I love it uh Yakuza right
there with the the Vans hat over there
he's still young he's actually a lot
older than he looks he looks incredibly
young
do you mind if I reveal your age dude
it's like 40 44 yeah he's 37 right yes
yeah we'll go with that you would pass
oh you're 38. oh damn it
[Laughter]
Steve and I think the way dude is like
you do like uh you know if you're scared
of heights you bring people to Heights
if you're scared maybe you should do a
whole gag episode to break him out it's
like a psychological thing yeah it's
like yeah it's called Contact therapy
and we can kill two birds of one stone
do the gag contact therapy at the same
time get you over your your homophobia
why yeah
just bananas in another form my friend
contact therapy night
stop Jim stop stop
it uh you so easy I sorry I
shouldn't have done this he's so easy to
make gag all right all right okay so on
Monday Governor Ron DeSantis threatened
a bunch of out of the box sort of
expansion projects that are in the
Disney World's special district here's
uh a clip from Governor Ron DeSantis
this guy really just does not give a
rat's ass uh in facing the Behemoth that
is Disney B maybe have another uh maybe
create a state park maybe try to do more
Amusement uh Parks uh someone even said
like maybe you need another state prison
who knows I mean I just think that the
the possibilities are are are are
endless and so that is now going to be
analyzed to see what would make make the
most sense and um and that wasn't
necessarily even on our on the radar
it's pronounced analyzed but
his team also released uh some pictures
of what the prisons interior might look
like so that's something we're fortunate
to have yeah
something's gonna happen he's especially
good at the drag queen story my what a
chick
[Laughter]
he's like yeah you got some nice land
there I think we might be able to use
that for the state yeah
put a park this comes from the fact that
and this is your home state obviously um
Mr Brewer uh DeSantis was announcing
this new legislation well some a bunch
of legislation but this is kind of one
of the more recent ones aimed at
eliminating Disney's self-governing
power this comes from a local affiliate
there is a bill that would put uh that
will be put out in Florida
sorry the Florida State Legislature that
will make sure that the agreements
purported to be entered into by Disney
are revoked and the people will the
people's will is established and is up
held and just to keep in context
this little warm people like oh
Libertarians will say oh oh why why you
want the government to step in now well
no no this also one of the legitimate
previews of government is to protect its
citizens and by the way states have
different rights than the federal
government right the state can do more
than the Federal Government Can this all
started over Disney's public opposition
to Florida's parental rights bill just
to be clear and that was that parents
have the right to know what their
children that's from NPR their uh yeah
uh hoodie parents have the right to know
what their children are learning and
that you will do not not discuss
sexualized topics with children's ages K
through 12. that was so offensive and so
beyond the pale that Disney felt the
need to come out and speak out against
it so what are they doing Disney is
saying no no no no it is a requirement
in a free Society in a progressive
society that we hypersexualize your
children ages K through 12. that's what
Disney did and so Ronda Santa said that
is actually violating the principle of
hurting our population most notably our
children and it's our job as the
government to ensure that you don't do
so entirely appropriate yeah by the way
I think it was actually worse I think it
was a k through three or K through
fourth grade that they were actually
saying that they could K through three
yeah so when you say K-12 it's like oh
18 year olds can't no no no we're
talking eight-year-old oh sorry
nine-year-olds talking about these
things with their teachers K through
three I apologize you should admonish me
uh that's close
all right
admonish no no go with the bigger
admonish no no that's a good one that's
a good one oh that's a good one we'll
get a bigger one later last free week of
mug Club lotto.com mug club uh also it's
the only place where you get to watch
the Friday show yeah shows this Friday
we're going out with a big bang not
going out I mean as far as it being free
it'll still be free for an hour for
everyone else who is not on my club but
Nick de Paulo show is there at 5 PM
Eastern okay
so DeSantis here's another interesting
point
um is there breaking news or something
that's uh are you sure yeah I'm fine I
saw a paper passed over all right but it
happens you guys passing notes no why
don't you read it for the class
these guys are children Tom says
Gerald's gay oh well yes I mean I have
that on my notes but it's more of a
header
that's interesting uh desensis is kind
of having this fight with Disney but I
like what I'm seeing with DeSantis I
would like to hear from you to comment
your biggest concerns about DeSantis and
Donald Trump we've talked about this in
the past and I've said you know my
concern with DeSantis is Donald Trump is
similar to Bernie Sanders
uh in that he is the one who certainly
brings in the most amount of small uh
donations right from from more people he
still does have big donors of course but
because he brings in so many small
donations uh from so many citizens he's
not nearly as beholden to big donors and
because so much of that money is going
to Donald Trump it requires that people
like DeSantis unfortunately rely on a
few bigger key donors my concern has
always been
not that I know he would compromise that
but there is a poll to compromise if you
have some more centralized donors and
this is why I like what I'm seeing with
the whole Bud Light uh Fiasco and
DeSantis speaking out against them
here's Ron DeSantis speaking out against
Bud Light and the uh the woke
advertising you want to drink Bud Light
I mean like honestly that's like them
rubbing our faces in it and it's like
these companies that do this if they
never have any response they're just
gonna keep doing it but it's part of a
larger thing where Corporate America uh
is trying to change our country and so I
think pushback is an order across the
board including with Bud Light I would
correct one thing it's not even
Corporate America it's a European
company
well that's fair
corporations that are in America
corporations that are in America but
that's also really important look cap
I'm a free enterprise I'm a capitalist
it ceases to work if you have external
forces who do not have a vested interest
in the success of your company uh in a
success of your country influencing your
country Free Enterprise in the United
States cannot work if China dictates
policy yeah as it relates to business in
the United States if Europe dictates
policy as it relates to business here in
the United States now you're you're no
longer in the realm of free enterprise
here's why that's so interesting I don't
know if you know Anheuser-Busch they're
pretty big DeSantis donor yeah they're
pretty big they've donated to the
sentence they have donated to
Republicans that is true but the fact
that he's willing to speak out against
it well that's a that's a good first
chance up at bat to show that it doesn't
matter if you give them the money he's
going to speak what he believes is right
well that's heartening to me I hope he
continues to do that by the way he kind
of painted himself into a good corner
there he basically said when you just
mentioned it Corporate America he said
pushback is is good across the board
right so it's not just limited to
Anheuser-Busch it's to these other
companies that are doing things that
aren't Un-American even if those
companies happen to be donors to his
political campaign because they play
Both Sides yeah no you're absolutely
right and uh are you you're DeSantis
Finn there Jim I am but I see this all
is just a genius brilliant evil uh
mobster move with like in all of it like
George Soros being in order to truly
take down the machine didn't get all
descendants in there we'll go after
Budweiser but his display will
descendants you will denounce them take
their money because they know we're
still going to make money in Uganda and
France Europe we don't need the American
dollar anymore however this converter
Trump tremendously why is your sorrow
sound like Alfred Hitchcock
foreign
but I don't know man it's all it's all a
game to me it's uh I don't I don't like
that DeSantis has Jeb Bush by his side I
don't like that DeSantis push the
vaccine and I don't like that DeSantis
uh lock things down and kind of pretends
he didn't yeah I don't like I don't like
that uh that Donald Trump pushed the
vaccine a lot everyone did and that's
that's that again where I say politics
is a great professional wrestling show
oh
[Music]
I have minuses and yeah there are some
things I'm apprehensive about with the
sentence and obviously with Donald Trump
and by the way I say this I have to call
balls and Strikes I hope this guy
understands it that was Ron desantis's
response to Anheuser-Busch who have
donated to his campaign let's compare
that to Friend of the show Donald Trump
Jr's response to you the American
people's boycott to the tune of six
billion in market cap and sales down 20
something percent over 50 percent in
some markets here's Donald Trump Jr the
company itself doesn't participate in
the same leftist nonsense as the other
big conglomerates frankly they don't
participate in the same whoa garbage
that other people in the beer industry
actually do who are significantly worse
offenders when I looked into it but if
they do this again
then it's on them
it's like Dad you counted the three well
don't make me get to four
what's well what's for it's a it's it's
a trans it's Buffalo Bill and a
Budweiser can how much more severe does
it have to be how much more badly do
they have to screw up Jim's about to
lose his mind I that one hurt yeah it
hurt on so many levels because
I I listened I I've come in contact with
Don and it just
that exposes so much yeah that it
frightens me well he's been on this show
a lot and he's a friend of the show and
I like him but it's very very and you
guys can comment below I don't look well
if you don't mind no go go go sir if you
don't mind you can't say they don't
participate yeah
you just Don yeah I wish I wish I had a
moment with Don before Ellis I know they
donated a lot but let this one go we've
got other beers that we can spawn I mean
like it was a bad move yeah and by the
way if you're looking for a better beer
just look to any other beer that exists
so it's not like you're limited
and this is also by the way why I will
say this there there are uh people use
the term grifter a lot and I think that
people often throw it around wrongfully
but it's why we don't some people said
why don't you start a beer company
it would be of no value there are
already tons of beer companies many
we've talked about Yingling you guys
have supported Yingling if you don't get
in there there are plenty of find your
local Brewer who creates the kind of
beer that you like or stop drinking beer
whatever it is that you want to do the
point is there are many options if I
were to come out here and sell you a 30
six pack like you've seen some people
out there doing calling it Freedom b or
whatever it is guess what that would be
me separating you from your money that
wouldn't be adding value now when we do
this show when we do things like change
my mind when this is an alternative that
I know it doesn't exist outside of this
so this is how we can add value if
there's a place we can add value that's
what we seek to do I don't want to just
take your money because you're
conservative that for me is a litmus
test for grifter I'd like you to comment
below if how you sort of measure it is
there really a need
for another beer in order to make your
voices heard with Budweiser now if it
was something where there was no
alternative right I would understand
that but this is not one it's just a way
to make more money and
that does worry me and you see that come
out every political season I think it's
incredibly Out of Touch look isn't this
here's the thing wouldn't it be great if
all conservatives Republican
Representatives look at the ground swell
here look at the grounds while a boycott
that is actually working it's not really
a boycott it's really more of a cultural
shift that is that is foundational right
now in how we move forward as a movement
here on the right and said oh okay
there's some real momentum here we hear
you and this is why people like Jim and
many of you if you're watching or
listening right now is you feel defeated
right you go oh my gosh what what if if
a six billion dollar reduction market
cap in six days and sales going down
double digits doesn't if our own leaders
who are supposed to fight for us don't
come out and what do we have to do look
we hear you you have done enough it is
enough it should be enough and anyone in
leadership in the Republican Party who
does not say that it is enough and does
not have your back on this is not
actively representing you this is not a
democracy it is a constitutional
republic meaning you elect your
representatives and that means they
should represent you if you think that
putting a delusional uh uh
[Music]
that was included I didn't really drink
Bud Light so it doesn't really it's not
really much of a sacrifice
your leaders
should be you should require of them to
stand with you because this is an easy
one and even for Ron DeSantis it's an
easy one and I really do hope and I
probably will be sitting down with a
president Donald Trump at some point in
Mar-A-Lago here in the next next couple
of weeks that uh that he does issue a
statement on this that he does make it
clear people make mistakes they misspeak
but this is one that is a win you do not
have to give up it's ground you do not
have to concede and we're going to talk
more about this and also about AI I
think uh here on mock club and if you're
watching on YouTube or if you're
watching on Rumble you can keep watching
on Rumble but if it's free this week and
then starting next week what you are
about to see for free will of course
only be on my club gymbrewer.com we're
going to continue right now YouTube hey
do you want to tell YouTube to piss off
I I can't wait to for the next I'm
chopping out the bit I can't wait for
the next hour it's champing I found out
oh Champion it's an equestrian champion
at the bit it still doesn't make any
sense but it's a it's an equest okay do
you want to tell YouTube to piss off you
want to do the honors well YouTube still
holds me a little bit so just just just
yeah piss off for now there you go